it's that time of year again cartooning
fans are gathering at the essen motor
show where 500 exhibitors are showing
off the latest trends
besides souped-up cars motorsports is a
big theme at this year's event
there are drift shows and exhibits to
mark the 25th anniversary of the dtm the
most successful german touring car
series but it is not only at the
racetrack the performance is tested to
its limits the 850 on this bravo stands
for the horsepower of the six liter twin
turbo the tuning package costs 70 000
euros so buying the car and the package
will set you back 279 000 euros the
bravo's executive sedan is an office on
wheels
alongside the shiny new cars there are
also many oddities both on four wheels
and two
such as this vw beetle that a bosnian
pensioner lovingly and carefully
decorated with twenty thousand pieces of
oak
when it comes to tuning tastes very
massively
actor axel stein likes a mat or a foiled
finish and big fat wheels but not much
more
and there are certainly plenty of big
fat wheels on display in essen
especially at the show and shine
competition
among the competing cars are classic
opals that were made in the rural region
opel has a special place at the motor
show
andreas marks who works for the company
says the brand goes where its clients
and fans are both the essence show and
the car manufacturer are rooted in the
rear valley and mark says it's the dense
population of the region that keeps opal
therefore the company also has roots in
motorsport and is using the annual
motoring event to showcase its atom r2
which will be used in a program for
fledgling drivers in the european rally
championships
both the astra gtc and the corsa opc
roadsters have a racing car look about
them
according to andreas marks there's a lot
going on at open and the brand is
enjoying an upswing consumers have
responded positively to the brand image
which brand ambassador jurgen klopp has
carried into the world of soccer but
they are also working towards creating a
positive image in the fields of
entertainment and motorsports
opel also has a new brand ambassador
although model lovelin doesn't have her
driver's license yet she is looking
forward to her personalized opal atom
but she doesn't want anyone to take her
for her first drive in it she is
determined to do that herself and says
it will just have to wait until she has
passed her test and there is another top
model at the opel stand the manza
concept the nifty coupe with the vast
gullwing doors gives an insight into the
future of the brand full of high tech
and a real looker to boot
this opel is already drawing plenty of
attention